that's that's how I actually get my work
it's not because I know how to take
pictures it's because I only wear gold
shoes when I come into the National
Geographic offices my name is Aaron Huey
I'm a National Geographic photographer a
lot of what I came into the magazine
with was really deep dives into
communities I think that kind of
intimate imagery was what I was known
for over the course of a National
Geographic career we end up with
assignments that are kind of curveballs
where we also may end up you know in the
Himalayas or tracking wolves and so the
style has had to adjust sometimes based
on assignment this was eight years of
going and visiting people and multiple
families adopted me as a member of their
own families and I had a home with many
people in stories about Pine Ridge or
reservations there's so much darkness
but this is one of those images of the
light you could throw a rock from this
spot and almost hit the mass grave where
they buried all of the bodies from the
massacre of Wounded Knee and there's
still a community of people growing up
literally in the shadow of Wounded Knee
and everything that it stands for I saw
the weather changing and I was 10 15
miles away and I was racing trying to
get to the marker to photograph that
mass grave in this moment of this huge
storm kind of circling overhead as I was
racing down the road to get to the
massacre site I saw these young couples
I had known them long enough that I
could just start photographing this
image has the light and the dark all
wrapped into one
something glows through there is life
there is love in the shadow of a
massacre site and there's still a
community of people living and loving
and fighting and surviving in that place
I feel that I think when I look at this
photo of the storm of this kind of glow
that comes from this incredible force
and
from these people despite the darkness
of that history job fiddled megabots to
vollum she de la de la who that's I got
like a song about friends having your
back like like a good old-fashioned
friends country song this is fun idea
this is a really isolated Valley on the
border of the Georgian Republic and the
southern border of Russia this
photograph takes me back really to my
own origins story as a photographer I
was in Damascus as a backpacker and a
german linguist told me this story about
a place where people spoke a language
that had never been written and they
were surrounded by 18,000 foot Peaks
that were God's turned to stone and
there was no guidebook for this place
and he drew on the back of a napkin this
this simple little map of the republic
of georgia and he drew a little line of
how to get from Syria through Turkey and
into the mountains of Georgia and I left
I think two days later when I finally
arrived in the mountains someone turned
around to me on the bus and asked where
are you going because there were no
hotels there was no place to go and I
just said I'm gonna go camping at the
end of the bus route and they just shook
their heads and they said we're going to
a wedding come with us and I ended up at
the wedding of the eldest daughter of a
family and I drank and I danced and I
woke up in the morning part of a family
and I went to visit that family three
years in a row after that I fell in love
with with that family I fell in love
with the song and the dance and the
spirit of this place and I returned year
after year for three years in a row and
at the end of that I had made my first
body of work it was all black and white
it was some of my first rolls of film
really and 15 years later National
Geographic sent me back to revisit the
same families
in this image I returned to a place that
I had already photographed and nothing
had changed
it felt like it was the same kids on the
same horses in a time machine there is
something still important I think about
these timeless journeys into other
worlds to just illuminate part of the
human spirit that's what this story was
for me this is a story that's really
it's just poetry the Denali assignment
was part of our National Park series a
lot of this assignment was about buffer
areas and about how humans and animals
interact I spent a lot of time with a
really infamous hunter named Koch
Wallace we had read stories that he had
set traps just outside of the boundaries
of the National Park which is not
unusual for a trapper but he had taken
an old horse in and shot it on the edge
of the park and surround it with traps
and ended up killing I believe one of
the alpha females and several other
wolves and that's kind of the goal of a
trapper is to be clever enough to set
traps and get as many wolves as you can
get this is a difficult part of the
assignment spending time with someone
with a really different set of beliefs
it's a challenge that's I think
important to keep taking on to like go
into the worlds of people that believe
something different and try to
understand where they're coming from I
had to go into a part of myself and
transcend my own biases and see him as a
person because underneath all of that
there were insights to the National Park
and to ways of life that I had not
thought about I still don't like the
idea of setting up traps on the edge of
the National Park but I understand a
little bit more about some of these
communities about trappers at the end of
a year and a half of work I was there
and had gained the trust of this man who
called me and said we got a wolf I'm
gonna skin it if you want to get down
here I think picture is like these
images of coke with this wolf are the
result of National Geographic
storytelling it's that a year in the
field getting to know a person or a
community and going deep enough
that you're the person they call that
really is what's special about what we
do here this was the quintessential
National Geographic assignment I got a
telephone call from my editor Sadie that
essentially said can you go to Everest
base camp and can you do it in the next
couple of days and can you be gone for a
month and a half I had to quickly look
at my calendar and tell my wife that I
was going to the Himalayas and then buy
all the gear that I would need to do
that and then got on a plane four days
later this story was really important
because we so often see the stories of
like the Western heroes on mountains
like Everest or these other Himalayan
peaks but behind them and behind kind of
this churning machine of tourists going
up these mountains are the real heroes
the unsung heroes of these mountains and
it's it's the Sherpa people who are
carrying the loads saving people's lives
setting up the rope lines that make any
of that climbing possible a Sherpa is an
ethnic group it's not a job I think that
was another really important part of
this piece was opening up the world of
the Sherpa people and going deep into
that community this is a photograph I
made really pretty much on arrival at
base camp it was like the beginning of
the assignment and it really summarized
a lot of what we were there to look at
this was a Sherpa carrying downloads
from the summit loads from the camps of
Westerners some of the Sherpa were
carrying almost their body weight in
equipment this story really dug a lot
into the compensation inequality is in
the lack of insurance and the kind of
suffering that happens behind the scenes
one of the whole points of being able to
do work that goes to hundreds of
millions of people is that we can change
the rules with it we can change the laws
this photograph is one of my close
sherpa friends and we're at the camp one
somewhere 19 to 20 thousand feet he's
surrounded by the Ravens the crows that
were circling around up at the
kind of one of those quiet moments
before the next big push up to Camp 2
and then beyond to the summit this is a
really special photograph for me because
I plan an entire trip hoping to get this
photograph I didn't want to climb
Everest I didn't think it was worth
risking my life but I thought I could
probably get to this spot this is AMA
Dablam
that's camp to the tents there you can
only fit I think four to six tents and
they're all tilted kind of sideways and
strapped into the rock and into the snow
there and this is done euro Sherpa
coiling ropes at camp - as his brother
and I are going up towards the beginning
of the summit climb a lot of my focus
right now is trying to understand new
ways of storytelling twenty years ago I
was shooting on a Leica m6 with slide
film and now I'm doing AR and VR work
that you know can be 3d printed or may
not have any print form ever there is no
one way to make or share pictures it's
infinitely flexible and it's going to
change beyond anything we can even
imagine right now
oh no I don't know I can't believe I did
singing that I'm not
[Music]